-I lied right to
Bill Polian's face.
He said, "Have you
ever held before?"
And I said, "Absolutely."
-What happened to the rest
of your hoodie?
-It's arm farm, dude.
There's no sleeves allowed.
-Somebody is trying to
chainsaw down our mailbox.
♪♪
-That's it.
We're a quarter of the way
through the season.
We know who's winning
the Super Bowl, Simms.
-Yep, we got it all figured out.
-Rams-Chiefs, 100 percent.
Look, every year, one team
starts off really great
another team doesn't,
and it's kind of become
the first four weeks are like
the extended preseason.
-Yes.
-And you've been telling me
for the last few days,
it's for players, too.
-Yeah, without a doubt.
I mean, it's the new age
of the NFL.
We know with all the new rules
that players and the NFL has
the coaching, the collective
bargaining agreement
the amount of hours and practices you can do—
-Right
—in training camp, in OTAs,
that's hampered game plans.
But I think the other thing
that we are seeing
especially this year,
we didn't see a lot of the stars
a whole lot
through the preseason.
We saw that this preseason.
-Yeah.
-Where guys like
Ezekiel Elliott didn't play.
Oh, you know what?
Week 3 and 4,
all of the sudden
he starts to go off.
Jadeveon Clowney—I know he
was dealing with some injuries,
but nobody wants to risk it.
Don't play preseason.
-Right.
-Now, all of the sudden
he plays the Indianapolis Colts
last Sunday
and we see the beast
of Clowney unleashed again.
-Two sacks, fumble recovery for a touchdown.
-Exactly right.
So, I think this is something
that we have to look at
going forward.
Alvin Kamara—I know
he's had some moments
through the first three weeks
but last week
against the Giants
he was a different guy,
exploding through the hole.
So I do think the early part of
the season, with the new rules
and coaches not wanting
their stars to get hurt—
-Yeah.
-The star players
are not really
getting into their prime form
until Week 3, 4, 5.
Earl Thomas didn't play
that much.
Unfortunately, he's not playing
again the rest of this season
and he showed
the Seattle sideline
how he really feels with this—
the state bird of New Jersey.
-Yes.
-A middle finger
probably right in the
direction of Pete Carroll.
And we wondered
what other NFL players
would love
to give people the bird.
I'm gonna let you go first.
-OK.
-Young guy,
been takin' a lot of grief.
-Right. Oh, Mitchell Trubisky!
Yeah, he's givin'
the middle finger.
You know who he's giving it to?
-Who?
-The Bears fans.
First of all,
"Oh, we don't know.
Is Mitchell Trubisky good?
Is he elite?"
He's giving it to his own coach,
Matt Nagy, goin',
"Oh, I don't have the full scope
of the offense?
Hey, take this!
Six touchdowns, everybody!
Back the eff off!"
-I'm goin' quarterback as well,
and it's, yeah, Fitzpatrick
and he's flipping this bird
squarely at Dirk Koetter's dome.
Dirk Koetter comes out to
the game and says
"I should be fired."
You know what?
Fitzpatrick agrees.
Your defense allows 35 points
in the first half.
Let's bench the quarterback.
That's the issue.
All right, where you going?
-Ohhh.
Good old Jersey Joe Flacco.
He knows how to give
the middle finger.
He's saying, "Up yours
Baltimore,
and all football fans.
You can keep Lamar Jackson
on the bench.
He can come in and run a few
gadget plays every now and then.
We're 3-1, and we might be
in the Super Bowl."
I like it. He's givin' it
to 'em right now.
-I feel like
this is to similar people.
-Yeah.
-This is to everyone that likes
to talk about the impending doom
of Andy Dalton.
-"He can't win the playoffs."
-"He can never get by!"
All right.
Well, under Bill Lazor,
he's been a revelation.
He's connecting with A.J. Green.
He's connecting with Tyler Boyd.
He doesn't even have Joe Mixon
-Right.
-And he's doin' this
with Giovani Bernard.
He's looked great.
Andy Dalton to the haters.
And a finger,
and then another finger.
-[Laughing]
-OK, gimme another one.
-How about Saquon
and Odell Beckham Jr.
-Triple bird.
-Saquon's goin', "Eli,
can you stop throwin' me
the ball one yard
behind the line of scrimmage,
and then I have to
play dodgeball
and make everybody
on the defense miss?
I'm getting killed out here."
And Odell Beckham Jr.'s goin',
"Can you just stand there
in the pocket?
I'm open downfield.
There's some one-on-one shots."
And I think even Pat Shurmur,
he's goin'
"Can you please teach
the O-line to block better
so we can throw
the ball down the field?"
-Man, they're flickin' off everybody.
-Three, triple bird.
-I got one more for you.
-You got one more?
-Superbird! Blake Bortles.
This was a middle finger
Blake wink to you.
-Yeah, this was a,
"F--k you, Chris Simms" week.
He should just get S-I-M-M-S
on his middle finger.
-I like that.
-And when he has a good week
he can just put it right up
there and tell me to shut up.
-You and Bortles,
not best football friends.
-No, we're not.
-Us?
Big-time best football friends,
and we took our act on the road
to take on the 49els.
The Ninels.
-The Ninels?
-Can you finish that, my friend?
-49ers.
-Thank you.
-You may shower together, but
we feel like we got you beat.
-Yeah, I think so, too.
-You guys don't?
-No, no.
-That kinda takes it to the next level.
-That's really weird.
♪♪
-How'd you guys meet?
-We worked out
every single day together
and then somehow got drafted to
the same team in the same round
like, 15 picks apart
from each other.
-Wow.
-As soon as I got drafted
instantly, George
on the FaceTime, just, "Ahhh!"
yellin' into the camera.
So it was a good time.
-That's a cute
little love story.
-This is about to be
a piece of cake.
-Can someone make sure
they're not cheating?
Oh.
-Oh, nice little warm-up
for you guys.
That's so cute too.
-Do I turn?
-Yeah, let's see.
-Bam!
I hope they get harder
than this.
-Got it.
-Yay!
-Oh, gosh.
This is layups for these two.
-Yeah.
-Did you really?
-Yeah, baby.
-What did you run?
-4.52.
-Wow! And Trent,
what did you have?
-I ran a 4-ever.
-[Laughing]
Something like that.
-Oh, no.
-Don't cheat.
-I'm so bad at this.
Damn it.
-It's embarrassing.
-It is embarrassing.
-I know yours.
-I know you know mine.
That's why I'm even
more embarrassed.
-These are the moments when
you question your friendship.
-It seems like it's around here.
-What did he guess?
-About as far away
as you possibly can get.
-You just—
like, you would know
if my birthday
was New Year's Eve.
-You seem like a December guy.
I just—
-I seem—
-You seem like a December guy.
-You seem like a former friend.
-Damn.
-What happened to the rest
of your hoodie?
-It's arm farm, dude.
There's no sleeves allowed.
-Arm farm?
-Oh, I tweeted that.
♪♪
-Stop!
-Y'all are givin' me good hints
right now
so I'm gonna go
for something like this.
-Oh!
-You were close.
-♪ I want Candy ♪
♪ Bum, ba-dum, ba-dum, bum, bum ♪
-That was a jam back in the day.
-It was a jam.
See, I remember things
about you, unlike my birthday.
-Dude, I'm embarrassed about
the birthday thing.
-I expect a present.
Rice, beans, peppers,
sometimes hot sauce
multiple scoops of rice and beans.
-That's crazy.
-Yeah.
-Orange chicken.
-Let's go, baby!
-Orange chicken!
-But you go a double orange chicken?
-I was honestly about
to put double orange chicken.
-Sweet and fire, honey walnut
shrimp, honey sesame.
I'll switch it up.
-How much money do you spend
at Panda Express?
-I like Chinese food a lot.
-Yeah.
-I feel like our connection's
definitely better than theirs
at this point.
-Oh, you do?
-More fluid.
Theirs is forced.
-Oh, yeah, I play quarterback.
Omaha, blue, go!
-Peyton Manning.
-Thank you.
-Greatest quarterback
of all time.
-Aaron Rodgers.
-Oh, my turn.
We won the Hall of Fame.
He's close to me. He's a relative.
-Phil Simms.
-Right.
-Overdrafted by
the Dallas Cowboys.
White linebacker.
-Three seconds!
-Oh, Leighton Vander Esch.
-Go.
-Oh, my old coach! "Spider 2 Y Banana!"
-Jon Gruden! Jon Gruden!
-Time's up.
-[Laughing]
-Jon Gruden! Did that get in?
-That was awesome.
-Um, quarterback for the 49ers.
-Jimmy Garoppolo.
Our best friend on the team.
Lived with us last year.
-JP Flynn.
-Celebration.
-Stone Cold Steve Austin.
-Damn!
-These are a lot easier
than your guys'.
-Just came out with an album.
Everybody listens to him.
-Drake?
-Yes.
-Um, he put my stapler in Jello.
No, no, no.
-Dwight Schrute.
-Yeah.
-I can't believe
we're tied right now.
♪♪
-[Whispering] We need to create a
good structural base.
-Agreed.
-OK, good
-What?
-How do we do this?
-Wow.
-We can do this.
-Hands up.
Go.
-OK.
-Big base here.
Do what you said.
-OK, big base here.
-Stop cheating, Trent.
♪♪
-You're going to
the second level.
-No, I'm not.
That's not the base.
-Break these in half.
-Let's get all the ones
in the base and then go from there.
-Trust me, bro.
-OK, fine.
I don't know what you're doing.
-You seem flustered.
-You've taken it upon yourself
to do what you want to do.
-Trust me.
-Yeah, you think?
-You're a base. "You're a towel."
-OK.
What, do you wanna connect it
over there?
-Oh, sh—This is not...
Holy crap.
-Lefkoe.
-Gimme another one,
gimme another one.
-Are we gonna go any higher?
-This one?
-Yes, it's fine.
-Gimme this thing.
♪♪
-Hands up, Lefkoe.
-What's up, guys?
-Are you f--king kidding me?
-Why didn't we just—that's
what I wanted to do!
-The champs are here, baby!
Let's go!
-Wooo!
-Still structurally—
-Wow, look at that structure.
-Stand strong, baby.
-Let's go!
-I'm really sorry.
-It's all right.
-Wooo!
-I should've known
your birthday too.
♪♪
-So, we took our first L—
Kittle and Trent Taylor.
-Jeez.
-Forgot my birthday.
-Well, because you decided to go, like,
diva wide receiver at the end
and build your own spaghetti—
you didn't listen.
No teamwork.
-He has no idea
what we're talking about.
-Well, it's all right.
-I want him to be our third
best football friend, Pat McAfee.
-Well, it's very cute you guys
both wear Jordans together.
It's really cool.
Oh, cheers.
-Jordan kiss.
-I'm wearing the greatest
basketball player of all time
LeBron James. Thank you.
-Laker.
-Yeah, you're a big Laker fan.
-I am also on that—hey, by the way, I
am also on that boat.
-Well, let's talk
about another GOAT
one that set the new record
this weekend
Adam Vinatieri.
-He's the best.
-Most field goals made
of all time, which is a—
like, Morten Andersen,
Gary Anderson—
I never thought those guys
could ever be caught.
Like, I thought
they were cyborgs.
You held for this guy,
but, like
everything I see about you, Pat,
is you have a great time
You can party, you
can hold it down.
And everything
I see of Vinatieri is, like
you know, he's very buttoned up.
-Yeah.
I couldn't imagine you guys
getting along at first.
-Seriously, I can't imagine it
either, actually.
-We were a very
yin-and-yang situation.
-Right.
-First of all,
when Bill Polian drafted me
I lied
right to Bill Polian's face.
-[Laughing]
-He said, "Have you ever held before?"
I said, "Absolutely."
I kicked and punted in college.
I said, "Absolutely, Bill.
I hold all the time
in practice."
I knew that was gonna happen.
They draft me as a punter
to hold for the greatest
kicker of all time.
-Yeah.
-Vinatieri calls me
to congratulate me.
He knew that I kicked
in college
so he said,
"Have you ever held before?"
And I said, "Absolutely not.
I lied right to Polian's face.
I am so sorry."
So, he flew me to Ken Walter
who was this holder
in New England.
North Carolina for, like,
a weekend
for, like, a "holding boot camp,"
basically.
-Wow.
-Laces out.
-Oh, it's a whole operation
because if you're off
by that much
if you miss—if I miss—
if Vinatieri misses a kick
and I'm the rookie idiot punter,
it's 100 percent my fault.
-Yeah, no one's
blaming Adam.
-Yeah, so we had a rough start
but we became
very close friends.
He's a great human being.
-I can feel the respect
you have for him.
-I held his balls
for a long time.
I mean, that's seven years
of ball-holding for the guy
and he was just so damn good.
-Talk about nerds:
Andrew Luck.
-Oh my God.
-Another guy that I—
I feel like you and him are
diametrically opposite humans.
-Yeah, yeah. He's so much smarter than
me—I would assume
a lot of people—but
me in particular.
-Yeah.
-Like SAT words.
He's just using things in his,
just, stream of consciousness.
-Yes.
-It is way over my head.
-Does he ever cut loose?
-I think he has some craft beers
every once in a while.
-Oooh.
-I think he's a craft beer guy.
Yeah, that makes me vomit.
I like the chuggable beers.
-What about Jim Irsay, though?
-The man.
-"Hey, Quinton. What's up, man?"
-All right, so this is the first thing
I wanna know, OK?
The owner's box with
the Indianapolis Colts
has a special glassed-in case.
-It's cuz he's burnin' cigs,
bro.
-So he can smoke cigs
in the stadium
and watch the game.
Mind-blowing.
-And it's probably the only one.
-I don't know how it's legal,
but I guess
when you own the team,
you can do whatever you want.
-So, he just built a glass box
to smoke cigarettes in?
-Oh, yeah.
And then he'll poke his head
out every once in a while
whenever there's
a special guest.
He'll give the wave
to the Jumbotron
place will go crazy,
back into the glass.
He's an owner that does
live and die with the team.
-Sure
-I've heard stories
of whenever I shank a punt
that there's, like, a
"Goddamn it, McAfee!"
chant in the glass tank.
-[Laughing]
-Right.
-So, he is a guy
that lives
and dies with his team.
-That's awesome.
-Whenever I retired
I had a great conversation
with that man, though.
I have a lot of respect
and appreciation for Jim Irsay.
-Sounds like it was
a hell of a conversation.
-Well, I mean, he took me
on a trip, you know?
He was like, "You know, they say
the people that are positive
they see the glass as half-full.
And the people
that are negative
they see the glass
as half-empty.
I've always said,
'Get a smaller glass.
The son of a bitch
is full to the top!'"
Yeah, it was 90 minutes
of just magic with the guy.
-What'd you get
on your Wonderlic score?
-Pretty good, actually—37.
-Damn. That's really good.
-Wow.
-Holy crap.
-What'd you get?
-Like, 24.
-Yeah, I've been able
to tell that.
The PatMcAfeeShow.com.
Pre-order.
Pat McAfee, professional
baseball player, where—
I never played baseball
a day in my life.
-Right.
-I played professionally
in a Minor League game.
We recorded the whole thing.
-So now you're a professional.
-I'm a professional
baseball player.
Yeah.
-While every other person needs
to see the games, we don't.
It is June 26
and we're making our Week 5
predictions right now.
♪ Oracle ♪
♪♪
-The Philadelphia Eagles
are 4-0.
Carson Wentz has played
all four games.
-Oh! Man, I think the Jaguars
are in trouble—1-3 start.
They want to bench their
quarterback, Blake Bortles
but they're the only team
that has other quarterbacks
that throw the ball
worse than Blake Bortles
so they can't even bench him.
-Jaguars start 1-3.
June 26—is that the date?
-Yes, it is.
-You are a Cowboys fan.
What is your record
after four weeks?
-3-1.
-Oh, OK.
-What is your bold prediction
on June 26?
-FitzMagic leads the Bucs
to a 3-1 record.
-Wow.
-Jameis comes back
and loses the fourth game.
-Oh.
-He goes 3-0, with FitzMagic.
-They go 3-0 with FitzMagic.
What are you smoking?
-And can we have some?
-Luke, what is the record of
the Kansas City Chiefs after four weeks?
-Patrick Mahomes, the
starting quarterback.
What are they doin' right now?
-I think 4-0.
-I think he's right.
-4-0 for Luke!
-Saquon Barkley, leading
all-purpose yards
Offensive Player, in the NFL.
-Leading Rookie of the Year
talks?
Sam Bradford gets hurt.
The Rosen one!
Josh Rosen comes in, leads
Arizona on a little winning streak.
Lotta talk, lotta buzz.
Week 5, Jets record.
-3-1.
-Oh, 3-1, okay.
-That's so optimistic!
-How did you become a Jets fan?
Why not a Giants fan?
-So, I'm from Jersey.
Parents, growing up, had season
tickets, had always been fans.
So it was, like, hereditary.
-OK.
Do you like Phil Simms?
-No.
-No, I don't like him, either.
Screw Phil Simms.
-That whole family's
kind of weird.
-Weirdos.
-My name's Chris Simms.
Nice to meet you, Cori.
How you like them apples, Cori?
-[Laughing]
-That was awesome.
-Amazing
-We like you, Cori.
-He is weird, though!
-I'm very weird.
Don't worry, Cori.
-He is weird, though.
-It's all good. And my dad's ultra weird,
so that explains it.
-June 26!
We kept the papers, Simms.
-We did. The papers, the papers.
-That kid, 4-0.
-Yes.
-He knew it.
He's the new oracle.
-The new oracle.
-Chiefs.
-I will anoint that kid
the new oracle for that.
-You have been anointed.
-Ahhh.
-That woman, though,
did not recognize you.
I assume that everyone
recognizes a 6'5" blond guy
that looks like Phil Simms.
I think everyone thinks
you're a Simms.
Apparently not.
-Sometimes, people think
I'm Boomer Esiason's kid.
You never know.
-Ahhh.
-But, being a Simms is–
-Yeah, what's it like?
-It's a great thing.
There was some weird
and some bad.
I mean, first of all,
I could wake up on a given day
if Dad threw three interceptions
in a game
might say, "Simms sucks,"
on this publication.
-That's gotta be fun.
-That's not always easy
to see your father
being portrayed that way.
Story that sticks out to me?
Giants beat the Denver Broncos
on the road, 1989.
I'm going to bed
later that night, OK?
It's about 11:00.
Going to bed a little late
for a nine-year-old.
Deal with it, OK?
And we hear a, I think, a
revving engine in our driveway.
We're like,
"Is somebody in our driveway
revving their car engine?"
We look out the window,
my mother and I
and somebody is trying
to chainsaw down our mailbox
to keep it
as Phil Simms memento, I guess.
I guess he was impressed
with the way Big Phil
played in that game.
-Wow.
-Question.
-Yes.
-How sweet was this mailbox?
Good mailbox?
-My mom had picked one
that would—
literally, the wood pillar
was, like, this big.
The guy only got, like, a quarter
of the way through
before the cops got there,
and he got busted.
-All because Phil beat Elway
and the Broncos.
-I guess,
and he was happy about it.
The guy lived in our town.
That's the weirdest part
about it.
-Wanna say hi?
-Hey, weird guy
from my old town.
How you doin'?
-Hey, guys,
I'm Marty Dumbledore
and you're watching a magical
show, "Simms & Lefkoe."
Lagardia levioso.
-Life after Allie is hard.
Ira, one up, one down.
I'm sorry.
The Rams are just too good.
Movin' on.
"Somebody & Lefkoe,"
another $250
a new somebody, same Lefkoe.
This time,
we're goin' to Central Park.
If you're ever near Central Park
and you don't know where to go
this is the guy to talk to:
Steve, Super Steve.
This is the staple
Superman shirt.
Every day is a good day
in the Superman shirt.
-Every day.
Every day is a good day.
-All right.
So, here's what we're doing.
I have explained to you,
"Thursday Night Football"
I'm going around New York.
I need random people
to pick the games.
Patriots are hosting the Colts.
They're 10.5-point favorites.
I want you to take me through
what you think
when you hear that.
-Patriots are home.
They have the edge.
I'm gonna have to go
with the Patriots.
-Ridin' that hot hand.
-Keep it going.
-Are you worried about
Andrew Luck at all?
-Uh, in general, I don't—
I don't spend much time
thinking about Andrew Luck
or worry about him in any sense.
-But Thursday, maybe.
-Maybe.
-All right.
If you win, we're gonna
come back, money in an envelope.
I don't want to shake it
around out here.
I don't know what kind of attention that's gonna draw.
-Definitely not out here, yeah.
-So I wish you luck, sir.
-Thank you, I appreciate it.
-Maybe we'll meet
in a pedicab next week.
-Sounds good.
-Ooh.
So my man Super Steve
is going Patriots minus-10.5.
-Ohhh.
I don't know Scuba Steve,
but I'm gonna ride with him.
-Oh, you are?
-I am.
I'm ridin' with a—what?!
I mean, New England,
the way they looked last week
it's Thursday night,
they're at home.
I don't know.
Colts coming off
a five-quarter football game?
-Yes.
-I'm goin' with Scuba Steve.
-It's Super Steve—
-Scuba Steve.
-And he has a oneness
about him
that I think, he is gonna be
our spiritual guide
into betting success.
-OK.
Sounds good for Scuba Steve.
-One thing that
we're very excited about—
you're very rude—
is the Jaguars defense.
Holy crap.
-Oh my gosh. Man crush!
-Trying to contain
Patrick Mahomes.
-Oh, man crush again!
-This Sunday game for us
is football porn.
-Oh, it is.
-It is so good that we want you
to join in.
If you're watchin' that game,
anytime you see something crazy
hit us with the "#FootballPorn."
-Oh, baby.
-Or if there's something
happenin' in your game
that's great—
great highlights, big hits,
big touchdowns
and you get excited,
#FootballPorn.
-Oh my gosh.
Completions, bombs
big plays, hard hits!
It's awesome! It's like...
football porn!
-Oooh, good job. That was nice.
-Thank ya.
-But this game for real, though.
-I mean, I'm excited as any game
I've seen all year.
-Are you more confident
in Mahomes having success
or the Jaguars
messing with Mahomes?
What's more likely in your mind?
-The Jaguars
messing with Mahomes.
-Wow.
-Yes, he's still young
and this Jaguars defense,
as you and I
have talked about many times,
it's one of the most
talented defenses
in the history of football.
-Much more talented than Denver.
-Oh, much more talented.
They play two
or three defenses
in Jacksonville
and say, "Screw you.
You know what we're playin'.
Try to beat us."
-In all seriousness, it might be
the game of the year.
-I'm so excited.
-It's our Super Bowl.
-I seriously have a man crush
on so many guys out here.
-For Simms.
-Peace out, homies.
-Holla, holla, holla.
We will see you next week,
and enjoy the games.
♪♪
-We even got
one of those things?
-Oh, legit. Next level.
-Wow!
Bleacher Report is the truth.
-That is one of those things
that's so minor
but it feels like
a really big deal.
-Unbelievable.
Forty-five camera operators.
Bleacher Report is crushing.
-It is.
-Crushing.